Okay, I'm scheduled for a follow-up PSMA scan next week to assess status of my prostate cancer.
I think I'm doing well with all the detox pathways, but I'm just wondering if there's anything special.
Anything special I should do in advance of and following the PSMA scan to detox the radiation
chemicals they use for contrast during the scan. I had them in supplement extra sodas and everything with them.
So a PMSA scan is a type of a PET scan, but it's so usually at a PET scan you're drinking a glucose
substance and then you're doing a PET scan and the PET scan is measuring the uptake of that glucose. So
highly metabolic areas that is cancerous sites will uptake the glucose more readily and it will show
hotter on a PET scan. A PET scan in itself involves radiation. So if you're going to do a PET scan you're
going to get you're going to have radiation. Now just at a regular PET scan do you need to detoxify
anything else? No, because you don't need to add anything to help detox the glucose the glucose
solution. You do need to add to help detox the radiation though. So we'll talk about that. Now with
a PMSA scan it's different. It's not just a regular scan, but you're also getting injected with a
radioactive substance that targets a specific antigen on the cell membrane of cancer cells called
the prostate specific antigen, that's PSA, but it's the membrane antigen which is a little bit different
than just the PS, the prostate specific antigen. So that radioactive substance is attaching to that
and it's a more specific than a PET scan for prostate cancer patients. So if you don't have prostate
cancer you're not going to get a ESMA scan, you'll get a regular PET scan. So you have really extra
radiation to detoxify. Now the positive about the scan it's going to be much more specific and it's
going to be more detailed to make sure that there is a spread of prostate cancer. The negative is
you're going to get more radiation. It just is what it is. So how do you detox that? Well you use
homeopause and you work on the detox pathway. So everything you already are doing like you mentioned
in your question, you're really working on your detox pathways. Is there anything else to take?
It's the homeopause. These two, this is our homeopause for radium. This is a homeopause from PHP
for multiple different radiation things. Both of these really should be used. So it just take them
just exactly how it says to take them right on the label. We put the instructions right on our label
and there's instructions on PHP's label. There are inexpensive little things to help you get rid of
homeopause work. So if you're taking doing a CT scan, if you're doing a regular PET scan, or you're
doing a PSMA PET scan, these are the two things that you would use. If you're doing an MRI, that's
different. An MRI is magnetic resident imaging that is not using radiation. You do not need these two
things. However, most MRIs are using a contrast die. And that contrast die with most MRIs
is gadolidium. So gadolidium is a different thing. So our MRI homeopause looks like this bottle here.
This one, but it says MRI on it. It's a different substance in there. It's gadolidium homeopause.
So use that if you're going to do it MRI. If you're doing an MRI with no contrast die,
whether you don't need anything. But if you're doing an MRI, a normal MRI that's using a contrast
die, it's using gadolidium, use the MRI gadolidium homeopause. So with the PET scan, use these homeopause.